alors tout part de d'un événement qui
s'est passé le 14 juillet 2022 l'année
dernière ou en fait à l'occasion donc de
du du feu fin du du 14 juillet
occasion du 14
[Rires]
pas n'existait pas donc en fait Denis
Brogniart qui était qui devait couvrir
l'événement de Biscarrosse de
tu devrais non mais c'était toujours
compliqué de me parler de trucs glauque
avec le sourire je veux pas que les gens
pensent que je me moque de cette
histoire donc en fait il devait courir
l'événement il était parti avec une
journaliste et il devait prendre en fait
un hélicoptère et il s'avère que ce
jour-là il y avait énormément de feu
dans la région et la journaliste a été
pris de panique et du coup elle a refusé
de monter dans l'hélicoptère et du coup
Denis Brogniart s'en est pris violemment
à elle l'aurait insulté ce serait voilà
mit très très en colère il y avait même
une chargée de prod qui traînait dans le
coin qu'on aurait pris pour son grade et
qui a d'ailleurs fini hospitaliser et en
burn-out et d'ailleurs on apprend on
apprend que six mois plus tard elle est
toujours en arrêt maladie et donc suite
à cette à cet événement qui s'est
déroulé l'année dernière donc TF1
dépêché une enquête et évidemment de
nouveau témoignages sont amenés et ce
qui est assez
pour voir si savoir s'il y a du
harcèlement puisqu'en fait les syndicats
de la chaîne se sont émis c'est dans
l'histoire et on demandait enfin ils ont
alerté l'adrh ils ont demandé à ce
qu'une enquête soit diligente donc ce
qui est assez choquant parce qu'on voit
un peu la réponse de de DRH face à cette
enquête c'est que on conclut en fait à
une un reportage compliqué qui avait des
tensions générales du en fait à l'enjeu
du reportage aux conditions de tournage
et finalement on minimise la le
comportement de de Denis Brogniart donc
c'est cette histoire donc d'hélicoptère
d'abord après il y a d'autres histoires
apparemment alors voici ce que raconte
voici ce que raconte que Denis Bonnard
n'aurait pas du tout apprécié ce petit
moment de faiblesse ça serait après la
journaliste il aura il aura hurlé dessus
il les a pourri pour tout le monde
c'était terrifiant toutes les deux
étaient sous le choc l'une d'elles a
éclaté en sanglots alors que l'autre est
resté pétrifiée incapable de bouger
comme vous l'avez dit voilà précise que
la charge est de preuves un burn out CV
à tel point qu'elle en serait même
hospitalisé cette fois il a clairement
dépassé les bornes mais tout le monde
sait que Denis Brogniart est capable de
colère humiliante en public surtout avec
les femmes c'est ce qu'ils disent
lis-moi employés contre Denis briards
dans l'enquête de voici son très
choquants secs cassant voire carrément
insultant l'animateur fait parfois vivre
l'enfer à celle qui partage ses plateaux
on n'est pas loin du harcèlement moral
alors moi quand je dis ça qu'on va on va
parler des autres cas moi aussi il
m'arrive voilà bien sûr voilà de de dire
des trucs voilà prenez des péchés c'est
plus des hommes voilà non mais de dire
voilà vite on est pressé maniez-vous le
cul tout ça est-ce que c'est là ce qui
voulait moi j'ai déjà eu affaire à Denis
Brogniart peu à peu près un article qui
lui a pas plus après ouais c'est vrai
que c'est quelqu'un il m'a pris la tête
pendant 40 minutes en hurlant dessus
c'est quelqu'un vraiment qui
qui peut vraiment avoir des colères
enfin il vous a appelé il vous a dit
quoi ça c'est ok il m'a traité de
journaliste de merde enfin ce genre de
choses quoi bon après voilà
c'est même pas moi qui l'avais fait mais
j'étais responsable de de la rédaction à
cette époque là on avait fait un en fait
il y a il a il était venu leur dans une
piscine pour pour un événement
associatif et nous on l'avait mis en
photo avec des lunettes et en maillot de
bain bon il était pas au top de salon
c'est que je suis une femme virilité et
bah forcément ça lui a pas plu on était
pas hyper méchant hein
la rédaction évidemment tous les cas
comme ça c'est pour bibi donc on me l'a
on me l'a filé et pendant 40 minutes
j'ai mangé bois après moi je sais je
sais prendre les manger pendant que vous
étiez au téléphone donc voilà donc c'est
toujours c'est vrai que c'est quelqu'un
voilà qui a des acides qui peut avoir
des colères énormes et puis surtout
quand il le fait par exemple comme avec
Charlotte Namur alors justement c'est ça
alors tu as pris l'enquête de voici un
peu compliqué Tony Brogniart aurait été
très violent avec mon ami que j'adore
Charlotte Namura excellente journée
sportive qui a bossé avec Denis
Brogniart pour l'Euro 2016 et la Coupe
du Monde 2018 en plateau elle était sur
le plateau pendant un coup du monde en
Russie en 2018 elle aurait eu un petit
bug au moment de poser la question
destinée au téléspectateurs et pendant
la coupure pub de Nil aurait alors
insulté très violemment lui disant
devant tout le monde qu'elle était je
cite qu'une merde tout juste bonne à
sourire
toutes les personnes présentes sur le
plateau aurait été choqué par cet
épisode on peut le on peut le comprendre
et toujours selon Voici Pascal obis qui
était l'invité de l'émission jour là
aurait voulu casser la gueule de Denis
Brogniart normalement il aurait dit tu
es mon millésime ma plus belle année
non mais c'est vrai non non il était
choqué du comportement de du journaliste
de comportement normalement c'est c'est
du harcèlement c'est du harcèlement
moral envers envers un subalter donc
normalement c'est condamnable c'est
bizarre que que la direction de TF1
n'est pris aucune mesure face à ça donc
ça après Charlotte paraît-il c'est
effondré aux toilettes elle dit je suis
allé aux toilettes je me suis effondré
je tremblais de tout mon corps elle
décide de quitter la chaîne en 2019
affirmant qu'elle a été délibérément
insulté humilié en plateau personne ne
sera de quel parler et dans un dans le
documentaire de Marie Portolano se
rappelle elle l'avait dit
elle vas-y elle elle avait dit que
l'animateur elle aurait empêché
d'assister aux conférences de rédaction
aussi sans nommer
typiquement le fait de dénigrer
quelqu'un non seulement lors de
l'émission et ensuite de l'écarter de la
rédaction en l'empêchant d'accéder une
conférence de rédaction c'est pour le
coup c'est vraiment du harcèlement
professionnel et TF1 n'a pas vraiment
réagi il y a que il y a que Thierry
Thuillier qui est le directeur de la
formation de TF1 qui l'a convoqué une
fois en lui disant que il ne lui
donnerait plus d'événements à couvrir en
direct vu comment ils étaient comporté
notamment lors de ce de ce 14 juillet
mais la direction des programmes alors
Denis Denis va donner ça sa réponse dans
un instant puisque apparemment ces
autres coanimatrices aussi on parlait de
lui c'est vrai que tout le monde voilà
parle de lui de manière pas très
positive Anne leur bonnet n'a pas trop
kiffé sa collaboration avec Denis
Brogniart elle dit question boulot Denis
est un grand pro j'ai beaucoup appris
avec lui mais il m'aidement c'était très
difficile ne supporte pas la Coop
présentation épique des colères folle
avec ses subordonnées c'est le prototype
même de la personne faible avec les
puissants et puissantes avec les faibles
Marion Jollès j'embrasse aussi Marion
pareil pour Marion qui affirmeront offre
à des collègues journalistes que sa
collaboration avec Denis Brogniart sur
le pire moment de sa carrière car
j'aurais méprisant désagréable givernais
il y a plusieurs choses qui choquent
Cyril vous parliez de on peut
s'engueuler etc on peut s'engueuler
on s'engueule sur le plateau on peut
s'engueuler c'est ce que je vous dis non
mais c'est ce que je vous dis on peut
s'engueuler et Denis Brogniart et
célèbre pour ses colères c'est vrai et
ses engueulades mais là ce qui choque
c'est qu'il y a une répétition du
système et la répétition c'est toujours
à l'encontre de femmes toujours à
l'encontre de subordonnée donc il y a un
lien hiérarchique de jeunes femmes qui
sont en situation de fragilité
professionnelle par rapport à lui dans
ses émissions où il est le chef donc il
a une tendance quand même à la brimade à
parler mal et cette violence répétée au
travail à un moment c'est vrai que ça
peut s'apparenter à une forme de
harcèlement c'est pour ça que Denis
Brogniart face à tout ça quand même à
tenter de circonscrire l'incend on va en
parler dans un parc et que TF1 également
a tenté de sauver le soldat brownien
alors est-ce que la fin n'est pas
négligeable
on va pas se mentir voilà ça fait
plusieurs mois qu'elle était uniquement
avec TF1 veut la bloquer absolument du
Parisien était prêt il y a plus d'un an
oui c'est quelque chose que qui était
effectivement dans les tiroirs depuis
longtemps et TF1 essayer de camoufler
camoufler l'histoire notamment je vais
pas utiliser des modifications
difficiles ou juridiquement condamnable
mais c'est sûr que quand vous êtes
journaliste et qu'on vous dit bah tu
pourras pas venir à tel ou tel endroit
et puis tu pourras pas couvrir Koh-Lanta
tu pourras pas faire ceci tu auras plus
de 10 premières en a bien sûr tu auras
plus Denis Brogniart en interview tu
auras plus tu réfléchis un petit peu
avant de sortir moi personnellement je
le je l'aurais sorti aussi non mais
après après moi je connais bien je
connais un petit peu Denis moi il a
toujours été franchement ça a toujours
été un amour on a toujours
ça ça veut rien dire à toi non mais non
mais non mais ça veut rien dire et c'est
vrai que après je te dis la vérité quand
j'ai lu l'article je vous dis je vous
dis je me suis dit franchement qui quel
animateur ou quel patron un moment ne
s'est pas énervé
auprès de personnes voilà
d'avoir une colère ça peut arriver de se
faire
quand c'est répété que c'est des humilié
que c'est des humiliations répétées et
publiques devant tout le monde et que
comme comme le disait par exemple
Charlotte Namura elle a carrément été
au travail
avec elle c'est un amour ça veut dire
que voilà elle était hyper contente
d'être là allez toujours souriante alors
son mari justement à
réagi la barricades soutient
inconditionnel envers toi marraine tu es
un modèle de persévérance et de courage
il aura fallu attendre quatre ans pour
avoir des excuses bidons et orchestrées
sans une once de sincérité il n'énerve
après Denis Brognard je t'ai vu rentrer
chez chaque soir en larmes je remercie
le ciel de ne pas avoir croisé la route
de ce lâche car cette sagesse qui me
caractérise ton n'aurait pas pu apaiser
la rencontre je regrette le silence et
le manque de soutien de beaucoup
d'hommes qui travaillent avec toi ou qui
ont été témoin de ses violences l'image
avant l'humain on connaît la musique une
chose est certaine c'est que le karma se
charge de remettre la balle au centre un
beau mot bravo à son mari vraiment très
beau mot Jean-Luc bravo Jean-Luc c'est
vrai que c'est très beau moi je trouve
ce qu'il dit et donc la réponse de Denis
mon regard quand il parle des excuses de
nuit moderne Jean-Luc qui dit Denis
Brognard a répondu à cette grande
enquête il a dit je suis très engagé
perfectionniste à l'occasion de deux
directs sur TF1 ou la pression est très
intense j'ai eu des mots qui ont dépassé
ma pensée des propos qui ont heurté
certaines personnes et je le regrette
rien ne justifie mon comportement qui
faisait suite à certaines difficultés
c'est fait isoler ne rentre pas compte
des relations privilégiées basées sur le
respect il a bienveillance que
j'entretiens avec les équipes techniques
et rédactionnelles des programmes
auxquels je participe depuis 30 ans je
tiens à présenter mes excuses à celles
et ceux que j'ai pu blesser Denis
Brogniart alors clairement deux versions
puisque lui il parle de fait isolé isolé
il se serait répété deux fois et de
l'autre côté on a une version qui dit
bah ça ça a duré pendant des mois et des
mois il y a déjà il y a trois il y a
trois femmes qui qui parlent et
visiblement y compris avec le poste du
mari de Charlotte Namura elle rentrait
tous les soirs dit-il donc il s'agit pas
là de fait isoler donc clairement là la
parole de l'un contre la parole des
autres alors moi ce que je dis je prends
l'exemple de Géraldine comme ça voilà je
me fais vraiment l'avocat du diable
voilà moi j'ai on se prend tout le temps
la tête ici peut-être il est arrivé
peut-être de rentrer le soir et dire à
Daniel j'en ai marre de de ce connard
c'est vrai
non mais sans rigoler mais après
toujours plus revenir le lendemain pour
dire ce que je pensais j'ai jamais été
baïonné j'ai toujours dit ce que je
pensais
hors des du plateau vous avez toujours
été extrêmement cordiale et courtois
avec moi puis surtout vous voyez peu
parce que j'arrive très tard
ça n'a pas été discourtois
voilà donc je veux dire tu vois
Géraldine c'est à dire que je me dis
peut-être parfois aussi il y a une
perception
je me suis dit est-ce que finalement je
peux enlever le parfois même si ça n'a
rien à voir est-ce que je peux par
exemple
remplacer ma position avec celle de
Charlotte non très clairement on n'a pas
vécu la même chose et on n'a pas on n'a
pas du tout subi la même chose mais ce
qui m'étonne aussi c'est en fait voilà
c'est vrai que nous on se dit les choses
et puis voilà mais on le dit en fait sur
le plateau que vous allez me dire la
même chose à Raymond vous allez dire
puissance 12 à agile vous allez dire
puissance 50
moi c'est tombé une fois deux fois et
voilà et ça a été peut-être une sorte de
moment très fort et un tour de climax
pour moi mais après on s'en expliquait
et dès le lendemain j'ai été ici et vous
m'avez jamais écarté j'ai pas été
muselée la différence fondamentale c'est
que c'est une situation de direct ou
d'émission avec une réplique possible
alors que là Denis Brogniart c'est
systématiquement or antenne au moment de
la vulnérabilité au moment où c'est
caché c'est ça qu'on lui reproche aussi
c'est d'avoir et d'ailleurs vous le
dites bien la face cachée de visage un
visage public certes autoritaire mais
sympathique et moi j'avoue comme vous
Cyril j'ai toujours connu
personnellement Denis Brogniart comme ça
mais là on découvre une face cachée
c'est à dire que quand il est en
situation où il va pas être publiquement
potentiellement mis en cause PAM il tape
et il tape très fort et les accusations
c'est quand même assez violent c'est à
dire qu'il a brisé des journalistes
l'horaire qui il aurait brisé qui
d'ailleurs qui d'ailleurs ont quitté
l'année dernière parce qu'on avait parlé
de cette histoire je l'ai appelé je l'ai
appelé en ami je l'adore cette fille
voilà je la connais on se connaît même
pas de la télé c'est voilà c'est une
copine à moi que j'adore et c'est vrai
que ça m'avait voilà c'était inquiet
pour elle je l'avais appelé et c'est
vrai qu'elle était extrêmement touchée
et je lui fais un gros bisou d'ailleurs
si elle nous regarde ce soir à Charlotte
oui en tout cas ce qu'il faut savoir ce
qui est certain c'est que pour TF1 c'est
un tsunami c'est une catastrophe totale
quoi qu'il arrive parce que ils vont
faire quoi justement c'est ça que je
voulais demander à notre ami parce que
que ce soit Koh-Lanta que ce soit
Koh-Lanta ou Ninja Warrior tout ce qui
présente
tout va dépendre de l'ampleur que prend
cette affaire si c'est énormément
parce que je veux dire on a bien vu pour
Patrick Poivre d'Arvor comment il gère
les choses en interne atf1 donc il y a
quand même plusieurs témoignages de de
journalistes qui ont été voir les RH
pour leur dire la façon dont se
comportait Denis Brogniart tout va
dépendre en fait si l'histoire fait du
buzz si ça atteint énormément à l'image
de la chaîne et et au programme que
Denis Brogniart dirige mais a priori il
y a peu de chances qu'il soit qu'il soit
exclu d'autant plus qu'il a fait un
espèce de mea culpa qu'on entendra et
qui peut en interne également faire un
mea culpa Castaldi quand même il y a
quand même beaucoup de cas pour
l'instant il y a pas de plainte on est
on est d'accord
moi je l'ai moi je l'ai produit de
niveau 1 avec avec Carole Rousseau sur
sur TF1 c'est vrai qu'il le la
co-production enfin la confrontation
c'est pas un truc qui lui plaît
énormément il veut tout simplement
à la vraie caractère c'est plus
compliqué de de s'en prendre à elle mais
je pense que là dans ce cas précis il y
a une répétition comme le dit Gilles de
de voilà de de comportement inapproprier
et puis ça dégrade
qu'on ne comprend pas que les gens se
demandent là
c'est vrai qu'on comprend pas ce qui
n'est pas grave
le mieux
[Applaudissements]
il y a personne autour d'elle qui la
soutient c'est-à-dire que tout le monde
prend le côté de Denis Brogniart elle
reçoit pas d'appel elle est pas soutenue
qu'elle est extrêmement isolée et
ensuite TF1 qui finalement et c'est
d'étouffer l'histoire parce qu'il y a un
papier qui doit sortir et ça ne sort pas
donc je trouve que quand même malgré
tout la chaîne et les collègues jouent
un Oui puis même il y a responsable
syndical qui qui parle dans voici qui
dit clairement que que les gens ont peur
de parler pour parce qu'ils ont
également peur de perdre leur travail en
fait alors c'est pas le même niveau hein
de d'agression etc mais il y a un
système à TF1 qui est quand même très
compliqué c'est-à-dire qu'à partir du
moment où vous êtes une star vous pouvez
dégrader les conditions de travail des
salariés qui bossent avec vous c'est
différent entre ce s'engueuler à
l'antenne voilà comme vous vous pouvez
le faire et
avoir des salariés que vous gérez et
qu'ils aient la boule au ventre pour
quand ils viennent travailler quand ils
viennent travailler
chaque jour avec vous quoi c'est
différent